okay this is a really cool attention to
detail in Starfield that I didn't even
know was a thing this is from Lexi
underscore underscore underscore
underscore on Reddit and it shows what
happens if you show up to the ryujin
industries interview in different types
of clothing if you show up in normal
clothes have a seat she doesn't really
say much you show up in a space suit a
full spacesuit corporate environments
aren't that toxic
if you show up off naked a walking HR
violation already
last but not least if you show up in a
giant ridiculous costume
it's when I thought this day couldn't
get any worse I wonder how many
variations of this exist